[Music]
he says this is the place huh
he wants it ready in two months
i can do that
all right everybody ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the first episode
of the jay and silent five secret stash
reboot come on let me show you what's
going on
you may have already heard that we have
moved or we are moving
the secret stash after 21 years in this
current location
we are now moving down broad street to
65 broad
so pretty much we just did a little bit
of demo today knock some walls down rip
some flooring up
my boy cav is giving me kind of car
blanche to do what i want
there's a lot of a lot of different
people involved i got my man mike zapsic
helping me out a lot of this stuff going
on here today
and in the next eight weeks mr walt
flanagan
will be involved in this back wall over
here let me show you
right there that back wall we're gonna
bring back the clerks
assad like quick stop we're gonna do
that right there
on that wall that's gonna be the new
home of the buddy christ
we're gonna build a nice shrine for
buddy christ there on top of him is
gonna be the blunt mobile
it's gonna be pretty badass so back here
to tell them steve dave crew
is gonna have their own room it's gonna
be like to tell them steve dave theater
we're gonna jazz it up for i'm gonna
give him a green screen over here
so they can do all the little uh video
skits that
you guys see out there all you people as
we run through here
we're putting get him back in the back
in the back here in his little cave
this is all the ebay stuff that he does
for you guys we'll all be
organized back here a lot of his
counters his computers
all the ebay stuff that he sells and
puts together you guys all be back here
so you're basically making the tusk
dungeon for him yeah
get it get him is going to get the tusk
dungeon you got that right and then
downstairs is where all the stores let
me show you that
all right so this is the downstairs
underneath the secret stash
the gallows this used to look like a
dungeon before i got in here but we kind
of cleaned it all out
two dumpsters full of crap brighten the
walls up so we can see down here we're
going to put new lighting in here
this is where a lot of the uh you know
the overstock of the stash is going to
be
comics collectibles merchandise clothes
that kind of stuff
uh and then back here is more storage uh
for the stash
cleaned it all up sealed the wall sealed
the floor and then we go back to this
big room
which is going to be bulletproof
dehumidifier system is going to have
some special stuff back there
uh it's going to be a fun project hope
you guys stay tuned
for the next two months it's gonna be
some good stuff baby
check it out and we'll be back again
with a new episode
of the new secret stash thank you
[Music]
you